[Música]
boa tarde a todos
obrigado antes mais por terem resistido
este calor que está na sala na sala no
ginásio
é um prazer estar aqui em viseu e
aceitar este desafio do pedro tal lhe
traz aqui hoje nossa voz
trabalho todos os dias e era muito fácil
para mim vir aqui falar sobre a voz até
porque nas aulas disse também que o
falso e 50
pensei a platéia vai ser
maioritariamente estudantes de
comunicação social mas não só de outros
cursos e nós temos outra voz bem mais
importante dentro de nós a nossa voz
interior que nos faz andar desafios
fazer caminhos e essa voz que me resta
quem consegue adivinhar
não há dicas estas imagens da guerra do
golfo e guerra do golfo nos anos 90
tinha 17 anos marcou marcou as nossas
vidas porque entrava todos os dias à
nossa casa dentro quer portugal quer
pela rádio e eu tinha sete anos e
consertamos em casa da minha avó que
vive em frente às nossas vozes em
proteger a casa dos meus avós tentava
enfrenta com visão enquanto estava no
telejornal
eu ligava o rádio ea minha avó sempre
tinha na cozinha e tirar apontamentos da
guerra que era no golfo e então com
esses apontamentos eu fazia ofício que o
que era o meu primeiro jornal eu fazia
um resumo do que dava noticiário fazer
um resumo daquilo que eu via na rádio e
depois mas fazem todos os filhos na nome
ou quase tudo mas chegava a casa e eu
obrigava a minha mãe a levar os meus
apontamentos para imprimir na papelaria
e ela trazia as 20 30 40 fotocópias que
eu podia e em seguida e na minha aldeia
porta a porta em todas as caixas com
raio colocar o meu jornal provar às
pessoas é que o que eu via e ouvia na
televisão e ouvia no rádio
no fundo eu estava consertando a ouvir o
que a minha voz eu sou jornalista era
claríssima a pouco fomos ali atrás da
questão do jornalismo de guerra claro
que sim eu queria ser porta guerra eu
queria ir para a guerra com uma máquina
fotográfica e fotografar aquilo que se
passava lá e com jornalismo ou fazendo
nunca sozinha estava lá dentro da área
nesta altura eu já fazia na escola
primária para termos um jornal na escola
contribuir porque todos nós uma coisa
tudo apontar uma arma e isso dava para
colocar a minha voz eu queria ser
tal como formação base e foi aqui na
licenciatura que mais uma vez que eu
tinha que ouvir a minha voz e trouxe
meus colegas vocês podem contar lhe
123456 comigo nós chamamos os
desistentes da comunicação social 2000 e
nós entramos 35 e nós acabamos tais nós
somos os resistentes o que defino estas
almas que acabaram a licenciatura dos 35
da fornada dos 35 que entraram nos
últimos quatro anos ea maior parte dos
nossos colegas não resistiu à voz
todos nós sabíamos desde muito cedo é
fazer a revisão da imprensa andré também
jr que acabou com sua voz e rádio por
foi no curso durante os quatro anos do
curso já queria ser jornalista que tinha
que parar para ouvir a minha voz em que
me sinto mais à vontade com que eu tenho
mais afinidade que faz fizeram uma voz
fantástica muito bonita
mas eu sabia que era aquilo que eu
queria e muito menos se paga uma máquina
fotográfica e havia na altura também
guerra em qualquer lado do mundo em
qualquer canto do mundo
e mais uma vez o serviço aqui hoje estou
aqui como exemplo para por aqui para
ouvir o que a voz para pensar em si uma
antena 1 ea muitas vezes para o douro e
ouvia mesma lenga lenga de sempre as
pessoas fogem do interior as pessoas
fogem do interior
então eu comecei a pensar se é se
esforcem no interior
por que não fazer o percurso inverso e
cultural
por que não ir para o interior onde
precisam de gente e nessa altura por aí
para pensar
é preciso tirar um tempo para pensar que
é uma coisa que hoje em dia e muito lá
na casa dos cliques do iatismo que temos
no dia a dia não fazemos isso não
paramos para pensar para limar o caminho
que vamos fazer
eu por aí ea via na altura do ic24
resposta negativa 3 positivas porque
todos eles eram anterior foi isso que
mais responde você tem cá ninguém como é
que vai parar
não vou mais tarde com o projeto que já
é muito importante eu saiba que ela faz
um estágio em 1965 embora fiquei oito
anos oito anos a ganhar experiência e
ouvir a minha voz
também houve um momento em que minha voz
e falou que eu tinha que sair
aprendi muita coisa comigo e trouxe
muito mais uma imagem com duas malas e
foi mais ou menos assim um caminhão
passar oito anos para trazer tudo que eu
trazia comigo a experiência e
reconhecimento humano eu estou muito
vinho é com 22 aninhos fazer o aumento
dos problemas noticiados detectados de
estado para a memória
depois estará em trás os montes 38 anos
chegou o momento de passar de ouvir
outra voz
isso é uma prática muito pessoal nós
temos o trabalho temos a vida
profissional e de repente a minha voz
interna deixa de ser só minha voz passa
a ser mesmo a nossa voz
há outras coisas que marcam a nossa vida
vamos criando e as decisões pois não
passa não só por nós e no dia que eu
disse tudo que andar atrás do monte seco
se profissionalmente estava como editor
há quatro anos pouco ou nada fazia
jornalismo rui era que o governo
implementou queria eu que escolher outra
vez à folha na caixa de correio a salada
externos
eu precisava de mudar para mudar mudar
já éramos quatro mostradores a minha voz
interior dizia ruptura total
não gosto estou cansado de fazer a mesma
coisa todos os dias na casa era zero
assim não tinha vontade de jornalismo
lembranças da guerra do golfo estava
longe
era preciso novo parar para pensar e
nessa altura eu por aí pensei que não
queria mais aquilo que tinha mesmo de ir
embora em um ano a procura de emprego as
coisas complicam mais a mesma o meu
percurso do muro a zona oriental nunca
aparecia em nenhuma oportunidade
a assessoria de imprensa eles vou de
novo para o litoral para o sítio onde eu
criei à procura de uma nova perspectiva
e quem pára quedas numa empresa fazer
assessoria de imprensa em comércio
internacional 00 ao fim de 12 meses o
que acontece é que em uma perspectiva
toda criada e de repente se viram
síndico não tem perspectiva nenhuma e
não era o que eu queria
entre confronto pessoal de imediato e as
duas funções quando entramos em
confronto pessoal ou aceitamos esse
confronto com a parte negativa e
deixarmos ovar ou aceitamos esse
confronto com a parte positiva e tiramos
o comigo o que de melhor o time e ele
ouvia muita coisa que era boa
primeiro era um conhecimento novo e não
percebia nada de logística internacional
dois anos depois eu estava precisando
muito de logística internacional
eu não percebia nada de marketing
passado dois anos criar campanhas de
comunicação para promover marcas
produtor português para conseguir chegar
ao estrangeiro eu estava aprendendo
alguma coisa de martim francisco tudo
conteúdo de conhecimento que eu queria
dormir e isso é bastante positivo
mesmo na parte mais negativa das coisas
há aspectos positivos
ele exige brincadeiras mostrou-lhes do
semestre passado
estamos a falar do caso nem toda a gente
tem custado rádio mal era né dos 70
alunos que eu tinha todos gostassem de
rádio nos toda a gente devia ter o
espírito de querer ser o melhor rádio e
também não queria atacar a imagem para
nada mas eu tinha que ser o melhor é
assimétrica da imagem está a mesma coisa
eu não gostava comércio internacional
ao fim de um mês ou dois eu sabia que
não era aquilo não era o meu caminho
mas eu tinha que ser o melhor gestor de
comunicação do cliente da empresa tinha
que ser o melhor
o que é controlado melhor mais uma vez
pessoas são paulo pontes são só dia
positivo com pessoas
se você perceber algum momento da nossa
vida que as pessoas é o melhor eo pior
podemos encontrar nesta passagem temos
porque o melhor de dois anos de
aprendizagem e precisa muito dela
acredita que precisa muito dela e agora
vamos a parte mais atual com toda esta
comunicação durante os dois anos em que
tenta tirar o melhor da minha ausência
do jornalismo tanto do setor de
jornalismo 2 foram ausências de
jornalismo
minha mulher está tudo em trás os montes
na carreira dela pessoal 12 anos de
farmácia hospitalar e pediu para vir
comigo cumprir a minha voz a voz do meu
sonho é importante ouvir a minha voz
interna e abandonou dela
por mim ela vai para o litoral sem
emprego e quando chegou o nosso emprego
um mês depois de um canto e agora voltar
a ouvir a nossa voz é voltar a pensar
quando já havia uma nossa voz
viver a uma só voz
foi um momento de pensar não é apenas
fazer o que eu estava fazendo
até o momento foi o momento mais pessoal
para saber de fato a mulher com quem
estava tão duro que aquela pessoa
nós desistimos nós estamos por lá custa
mais que um e todas tomadas em função do
nosso e queremos continuar
outra vez a bela fase
parei para pensar cheguei à conclusão
que não vale a pena estar a investir uma
coisa que apesar de tentar ser o melhor
possível e eu tentei sempre fazer o
melhor que eu conseguia mas não era
aquilo que eu queria então no no dia em
que a pesquisa faz um tratamento de
radioterapia eu disse amanhã vamos pedir
concorda
são conversas assim de pão ela sabia que
estava desmotivado que não era aquilo
não era o caminho ela concordou no dia 5
está a apresentar a carta de missão e em
prol do emprego e pensar em
trás-os-montes dá aulas no piaget
durante dois anos
é uma coisa que gosto de fazer essa
informação como formador vou montar a
tenda tentar na formação e acreditam na
ironia do time ao longo de cinco das
várias portas e uma porta que se abriu e
temos imensa informação passe em
logística internacional e dois meses
o internacional em casa exausto
satisfeito com o que eu estava a fazer
um colega do jn tinha acabado de ser
despedido
miguel a uma rádio nacional está à
procura de um correspondente à zona
centro do país para fazer coimbra e
aveiro miguel sou eu quem tem que falar
é quem tem que enviar em entrevistas
debates e acompanhamento dos seus
autarcas com uma carta muito emocional
grande provavelmente mais chamativa e
explicar não tanto porque silva aguiar
que eu gostava das peças mas o quanto eu
estava dentro de voltar ao meu caminho a
minha voz quando tinha sete anos
e eu chamei o dia d porque eu enviei
estudo ao arsênio rádio tsf que ouviu e
que não ligou e pedro pinheiro levaram
os dois para uma reunião a lisboa
eu fui à reunião pensar vamos dar
entrevista
vamos ver no que isto dá quando sai do
ar
vinha com microfones da tsf com o clube
na mão de vocês não imaginam os públicos
que é possível pular enquanto conduzia
os pulos vai fazer o trajeto entre
lisboa eo namorado foi o regresso ao
encontro com mais gosto de fazer e nesse
dia
a mulher sofreu mais uma vez ela está ao
lado o mesmo vai ser pobre toda a vida
ela tem razão eu não me importa porque
eu gosto mesmo acumulando com outras
coisas é vovó para discutir com o livro
traz razões primeiro porque nós temos
que fazer fato é que nos apaixona na
vida eu gosto muito de correr
corro há bastante tempo e faça o futuro
isso estar bem comigo próprio passaria a
correr querem vencer ótimo é o objetivo
deles vida o meu não é que eu entrei nos
trailers e até aquelas corridas para
minha satisfação para ouvir a minha voz
mas ouvir a minha voz e quando chega em
casa toma decisões em curso
o trajeto se hoje estou aqui nesta terra
pedro e também foi voltar em 2012 e
também por mim mas por por aí para
pensar na minha voz giro por quê
um trailer quando o mesmo ligou a
perguntar se eu queria pedir uma
entrevista e eu disse sim eu quero tinha
durante o troféu pensado muito no
caminho que eu conhecia e é esse caminho
era o que era nossa voz em tudo tudo
aquilo que vocês passam por favor
coloque a paixão de viver
obrigado
[Aplausos]